.
(applaudissements)
- Le cri du coeur de Gabrielle
Boulianne-Tremblay a été entendu
par pluslui remettent leur granx
dans la catégorie roman.GABRIEL,
écrivaine et comédienne
- Ça me touche énormément parce
aventure ce roman-là. C'est
quinze années d'écriture.
- Née à St-Siméon, Gabrielle
Boulianne-Tremblay s'est sentie
féminine dès l'âge de
même" est en partie son
histoire, celle d'une femme
trans.
- C'est en fait d'une petite
fille trans qui ignore
le Québec rural des années 90.
Je suis allée vraiment écrir
été, l'adolescentee que j'ai
été. Je suis aller m'adresser à
cette fille-là. Puis après ça,
je me suis juste d
écrire avec le coeur, avec
les trippes.
- Dans ce récit immersif,
l'autrice n'hésite
raconter qu'elle a été déjà
agressée.
d'écrire là-dessus pour
me libérer aussi de certains
traumas quoiqu'il y en a encore.
Ça reste imprimé en nous.
- Pour des libraires du Québec,
"La fillême" est un
roman important dans l'histoire
de la littérature
KATHERINE FAFARD, DG Association
des libraires du Québec
- J'ai adoré. C'est un livre...
Même si c'est une histoire d'une
enfant trans, j'ai trouvé que
c'était récit universel dans
lequel oreconnaître
même si on n'a pas vécu ce- Ause
Boulianne-Tremblay a joué
notamment dans le film "Ceux qui
font les révolutions à moitié
n'ont fait que se creuser un
tombeau". Cette militante pour
la communauté LGBTQ plus espère
que son oeuvre conmentalitésmen.
- Je ne pense pas qu'il y a 10
ans, ce roman aurait eu cet
accueil-
qui n'était pas pour ce livre-
là, qui étaient réfractairréfraà
le lire, et qui ont fait
le pari dans cette
aventure-là et qui en sont
sortis grandis. Alors pour moi,.
- Un beau sourire. Comme ça,
c'est parfait.
- Avec ce Prix des libraires
vendus pour "La fille d'elle-
même", la suite  en
cours d'écriture. Ici Louis-
Philippe Ouimet, Radio-Canada,
Montréal